marre marre marre marre automne 1995 la
france est paralysée par la grève train
à l'arrêt métro fermée pendant ce temps
les français ram
retour sur ces deux mois au ralenti du
marché tellement qu'on en a marre ras le
bol les français protestent contre la
réforme des retraites dans la rue tout
le monde y passe les fonctionnaires les
étudiants l'hôpital et surtout les
cheminots le mouvement se fait
particulièrement dure à paris le 10
octobre et un mardi noir
le seul espoir de se déplacer c'est
d'attraper l'un des rares bus en
circulation
sinon il reste les souliers et les
pédales les mains vous prenez votre vélo
non demain je vous prends le métro les
horaires si ça marche espère plus que
d'espoir c'est de patience qu'il faut
s'armer à paris comme en régions
les nerfs sont mis à rude épreuve ici en
gare d'angoulême bloqués comme tant
d'autres quelqu'un appelle une
manifestation
pour manifester contre les cheminots de
la sncf
ce que y'en a marre marre marre marre la
grève de 1995 et historique
les français ne s'était pas autant
mobilisés depuis mai 68
alors forcément la télé sont fait l'écho
jour le jour avec une attention
particulière portée aux naufragés des
transports qu'est ce que vous pensez de
tout temps l'homme déjà monsieur je vais
tellement et agressif que ça passera pas
à la télé le dispositif médiatique est
de taille le jt prend la voie des airs
et ça donne à l'exercice du point route
at on appris le revenu vers le pont de
nogent la grève de 95 ce sont aussi des
moments de grâce comme ce jour de
décembre où les souliers usés ont trouvé
un peu de répit dans les navettes
fluviales sur la scène la vie enfin
banon c'est très bien parce que jamais
sur la scène alors merci passer des
moments aussi de solidarité à paris
entre collègues c'est partage d'appart
s'il ya des personnes qui sont
intéressées
ben aucun problème je peux les héberger
gratuitement
la seule chose c'est que je fais pas la
cuisine et surtout partage de voiture je
rencontre des personnes que je ne
connaissais pas et ça me permet de
discuter en voiture et d'attendre
patiemment que les embouteillages se
tiendront donc ça ne pose aucun problème
après cette expérience de
débrouillardise les premières
plateformes téléphoniques de covoiturage
ont été lancés en france la pratique a
survécu à la fin du mouvement le 15
décembre 1995
[Musique]